he asked why did you bomb
at the company I was just going to let
that go
share with you I got my laugh and I'm
done I got you I'll share it with you
okay all right all right so last night
um so it was a Monday yeah oh yeah so
Monday night and I get a call yeah
you're up at 11 45.
on a Monday
right and I you know I try to get out
you know how you try to get out
my little knee hurts or whatever you
know I mean I have my the tires why are
you say this like a set what you're
saying it like a set like what are you
gonna set oh I got stand up yeah yeah
because when I talk to
uh people that book comedy shows I do it
as if I'm doing right I mean right what
is that all about you know why 1130 you
know but I show up and uh and the show
hadn't even started uh you know so I I
couldn't even make it till 11 45. I know
at my age you know we're the same age
are we the same age I don't know yeah no
I bet him oh this is a fun game I'm 56.
you're older yeah see about 52. yeah but
same but still 11 45. yeah it's crazy
it's crazy and then I'd have to go to I
should set an alarm to wake up and be
there you know like go to bed and get
yeah you know but it was sold out too
packed yeah in the main room right I
show up and it's like everyone like
Esther Whitney Cummings Andrew Santino
we're all in the back and everyone did
terrible oh wow yeah it was rough but I
was like later in and then once I I you
know
check this out
a covert monster
[Laughter]
no so once
you know they were honestly I was in my
mind I was like you know what I want to
be the guy yeah oh they're struggling
but I'll crack the code I'm gonna Crack
the Code yeah yeah I mean with energy
yeah right and Charisma right right and
I'm gonna bust her they didn't also I'm
the only ethnic right right so I'm gonna
give them that stuff sure
Little People yeah they're gonna
want it they're gonna love all that
stuff right so I gotta go get my big hat
so you know they call my name I come out
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah let
me love me
and they hated it oh boy because they
they realized what I was doing eat
pandering not only pandering they're
like oh he's doing the ching chong oh no
he's he thinks that that's going to be
the way to our heart wow but we refuse
and you know what because you tried
we're gonna reject you more
the audience collectively said that as a
group right and two minutes in
because it's so hot because the global
warming and stuff right and I'm just
like sweating my face is sweating right
and and you know when you get the light
that means you have three more minutes
yeah not last night that means good
night bye bye bye bye yeah and then so
funny I get off stage and Eric Griffin
was next because how was it man I got oh
my God it was so hard you got any you
could see in this face yeah that I got
it oh he's gonna be the guy
oh that's great
to watch him suffer I mean it was so fun
to see my friends suffer and he even was
even worse right so because they're
tired they're more tired at this point
yeah but it's also they're more like you
could tell by looking at audience
they're more
um
they're edgier you know they're more
like Gothic oh wow
at The Comedy Store Gothic no no I'm
saying it wrong
no it wasn't the theme not I think
that's the wrong word I think they're
more like you know um you know just more
like they all look like David Grohl oh
wow yeah yeah you know I mean like you
know they all look like you know we're
cool yeah yeah I mean we've seen it all
yeah you know La sure some audiences I
live here
get out I do I don't know I want you to
get out of town
well how long you been here
uh I've been here well in this stretch
since 2001. what do you mean stretch
error I mean because I lived here before
that for like you know a year and then
six months you know like in in chunks
and so like but I've been a solid Los
Angeles resident since